alors premier conseil pour je vous dis
reprendre du poil de la bête c'est trop
optimiste
quand on est optimiste on vit 7 ans de
plus en bonne santé c'est pas vrai donc
tu es super optimiste
c'est-à-dire il nous arrive par exemple
on perd une
immunité chute quand pour les
pessimistes c'est pas bon détende moins
bien
donc faut voir la vie en rose
pessimiste moi le pire à chaque fois
j'anticipe le pire mais j'ai
l'impression qu'en anticipant le pire il
va m'arriver le meilleur est-ce que
c'est vrai docteur
mais vous dites aussi de la même chose
de la région oui si on est religion on a
7 ans d'espérance de vie en plus
croyance les sujets et je vais vivre
jusqu'à quel âge
attendez les gars et optimiste et merde
effectivement les gens qui croient une
religion qui ont un sens profond dans
leur vie pour vivre également s'étendre
plus que les autres ça booste l'immunité
et ça fait que les gens sont beaucoup
plus fort mentalement et physiquement
vous avez fait du sport c'est normal
un petit truc pour pour être optimiste
c'est quand on parle ne pas utiliser le
noeud ou le pas ne pas mettre de
négation aussi et donc ça permet de
réfléchir c'est à dire voilà on dit pas
ne pas on met pas de négation on essaye
de tourner la phrase pour que ce soit
une phrase positive et du coup
parce qu'en fait ce que tu dis tu la
pensée est-ce que tu penses tu le sais
en énergie c'est une étude américaine
qui disait que par exemple il faut
éviter les problèmes par exemple dans
une société on te dit ne dites jamais le
mot problème difficulté dit on a il y a
quelque chose à résoudre ne pas dire de
mots négatif
c'est prendre des douches froides ah oui
ça va nous redonner le moral ça la
douche froide c'est extraordinaire au
début on commence avec l'eau tiède sur
les jambes mais quand on est bien
habitué et on garde le moral même si on
quand on voit son kiki alors
justement oui non c'est un vrai sujet
parce que sous la douche froide il y a
des hommes qui veulent pas le faire
parce que les testicules remontent non
jusqu'au
bout ça remonte pas jusque là d'accord
donc là il y en a qui peuvent pas le
faire parce que les testicules
recherchent la chaleur donc monte vers
l'abdomen moi j'étais à la maison j'ai
retrouvé mes testicules et j'étais dans
un sauna tranquille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
et en plus bon c'est bon pour la planète
une douche froide 2 minutes c'est le spa
de rêve et le plus économique on a une
forme ou le matin jeunesse compliqué à
faire ça dépend du milieu le matin ou le
soir du coup le matin c'est très bien le
soir aussi on sent une énergie et
surtout le matin le soir le moral est au
meilleur avec ça essayez vous allez voir
c'est formidable moi je fais tout le
temps des douches froides ah oui j'en
fais souvent parce que c'est assez bon
pour c'est la Cryo ça améliore le retour
veineux c'est formidable
je vais prendre un balai
docteur je lis beaucoup de choses aussi
pas confrère mais je connais un petit
peu la médecine et c'est vrai que moi
j'avais lu là je suis sérieux le matin
la nuit la température de votre corps
baisse et le matin il faut prendre une
douche chaude et directement la
température remonte vous êtes en forme
je reconnais que c'est ce que je fais et
tout de suite je suis réveillé donc la
douche froide le matin vous allez
rebaisser encore la température du corps
vous êtes une loque non non pas du tout
pas de bêtises plus la température du
corps est basse mieux c'est pour la
santé on s'aperçu par exemple les
centenaires ont une température un peu
plus basse que les autres c'est sûr
qu'ils aient pas déjà morts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
écoute je l'ai touché elle était d'une
elle était toute froide elle pète la
forme écoute un thermomètre dans Daniel
c'est intéressant parce que par exemple
moi quand j'ai de la quand j'ai 37 c'est
déjà que j'ai de la fièvre parce qu'on
en général je suis à 30 vous êtes plutôt
froide
et donc en fait vous me dites que c'est
pas je m'inquiétais un petit peu je
m'étais parce que le proie concept mais
c'est vrai on a pris par exemple des non
mais non mais
plus à 34 35 toi non mais je veux dire
oui mais oui bah oui froide c'est les
Américains
c'est américain c'est loklahoma tout ça
oui docteur le froid sur le visage
excusez-moi arrêtez de lui en même temps
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe non le froid
en fait fait du bien la santé d'ailleurs
des je travaille sur une petite souris
qui s'appelle Laura taupe nu qui est à
32 degrés qui vit 30 ans alors qu'une
souris des deux ans qui a donné
le froid fait beaucoup de bien ah bah
alors troisième conseil il faut éviter
de manger gras et sucré
on s'aperçut que les gens qui
beaucoup de fast food beaucoup de choses
graves sucrées
morales en berne et ce qui fait du bien
ah oui non mais faut se libérer ça va
aller mieux
tu appuies comme ça où je veux là vas-y
dis 33 33
merci Mathieu merci alors non ou alors
donc il faut manger il faut éviter de
manger gras et sucré
je savais pas que ça joue ah c'est pas
bon du tout c'était très bien le
documenté le manche grêle sucré plus on
déprime au contraire des légumes manger
des fruits des légumes donne la pêche
c'est sûr parce que je travaille pas
la gueule quand je me retrouve avec
devant mes haricots verts et les colis
je peux vous dire que je suis en train
là ce soir si je mange une pizza ou un
truc je vais être content pourtant le
chocolat
extraordinaire pour la santé
noir noir
le 100% par contre est un coupe-faim
formidable pour les deux carrés
tellement
pris dans la gueule tu as plus envie de
manger t'évanouit il faut pratiquer pour
le moral aussi le jeune séquentiel je ne
séquentiel on a découvert que si on a on
tient 16 heures sans manger mais en
buvant beaucoup de l'eau du thé il y a
même des mélanges de
et bien à ce moment-là on sécrète une
petite molécule qui s'appelle BDNF qui
fait qu'on a b DNF avec cette petite
molécule qu'on sécrète quand on est en
jeu on voit la vie en rose on a un moral
du tonnerre en fait c'est la fin qui
fait du bien c'est la fin qui fait du
bien
l'orthographe c'est pas leur spécialité
non mais c'est faisable alors pour avoir
le moral donc je te dis Daniel c'est
mort pour toi tu auras jamais le moral
faut faire l'amour 12 fois par mois
comment vous dites il faut faire l'amour
pour avoir le moral en fait
12 rapports sexuels
par mois non mais si on en a par exemple
dans la même nuit 7 ou 8 ça monte
vous êtes à
votre exceptionnel
pas de moi mais on sait jamais
c'est ça tu fais un très mauvais toi
c'est-à-dire ouais c'est ouais c'est
vrai que 12 rapports par mois augmente
de 10 ans l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé
[Rires]
nous sommes passionne et je regarde
beaucoup de conférences la moyenne de de
rapport des couples en France c'est 1,1
fois une fois par quoi par semaine mais
bien sûr que ça fait 10 ans que tu es en
couple personne se saute dessus quand tu
rentres arrêter vos conneries donc ça
veut dire que en gros non non mais la
masturbation marche pas non mais
j'entends bien ça donne pas le même
piquez-moi quel couple normal après 10
ans ça fait trois fois l'amour par
semaine sans mentir c'est beaucoup plus
fréquent
ah oui mais non absolument
le demi non mais
il faut faire 30 minutes d'exercice par
jour pour avoir le moral aussi
c'est extraordinaire on a vraiment c'est
le physique qui avait aidé le mental et
en plus on baisse le 40 % de cancer
Alzheimer maladie cardiovasculaire on
doit le faire tous les jours sur monstre
je suis un monstre quand tout ce que
vous dites je suis un monstre je coche
toutes les cases non non pardon la pizza
le soir oh mais non je mange du chocolat
85 %
je considère que toute mort avant 120
ans est une mort prématurée et vous êtes
sur la bonne voie Daniel vous aimeriez
que le doyen de l'humanité bien sûr ah
bah franchement ça ferait chier beaucoup
de monde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parlerai des journalistes tout à l'heure
il faut s'exposer au soleil à la lumière
à vous vous l'êtes j'ai rien je voulais
être posé au soleil à la lumière peut
mourir demain tu me vois tous les jours
depuis tout à l'heure
le soleil à Paris toute la journée la
lumière c'est vrai qu'entre novembre et
mars il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
font des dépressions on appelle ça le
SAD sad par manque de lumière c'est bien
identifier d'ailleurs dans hôpitaux il y
a des salles avec de la lumière pour que
les gens viennent s'exposer la
luminothérapie exactement et alors
aujourd'hui un truc je le dis je le dis
je donne mon conseil beauté
un espèce de masse comme ça que je mets
3 minutes par jour mais c'est un vrai
masque que je mets comme ça et j'appuie
en fait il y a de la lumière 3 minutes
par jour je fais ça c'est vrai ça alors
86 % des ventes chez les homosexuels
[Rires]
c'est incroyable et vous le faites
vraiment régulièrement oui bah tous les
jours 3 minutes en fait tu appuies ça
dure 3 minutes et c'est incroyable on
sentait mieux après mais de fou
il vaut mieux le faire le matin parce
que ça peut perturber le sommeil
qu'est-ce que tu as toi qu'est-ce que tu
as et quand pardon en fait des choses
quoi j'étais dans ta loge l'autre jour
parce que j'étais avec Kelly
il y a des trucs pourtant des sourcils
tu as une crème de grande marque tu as
un truc pour les sourcils tel qu'un truc
de luminothérapie non non pardon c'est
pas métro sexuel c'est homosexuel c'est
pas
pas grave
c'est pas grave
chez moi j'ai pas ça le problème
alors 8e conseil il faut garder une
bonne quantité de sommeil
très important 7h30 de sommeil minimum
et moi je fais neuf
j'arrête à 9 mois
le moral est bien meilleur et ça donne
de l'énergie alors les pompiers dormir
pas les médicaments masque de sommeil
noir cette fois-ci si on n'a pas le noir
une petite diode de rien du tout et on
dort mal
et alors et on coupe le chauffage dans
la chambre en fait au froid
les trois fois sexuelles par semaine tu
en es où
pourquoi tu me demandes ça le docteur je
te le demande
merci Raymond de m'avoir sauvé une fois
je le coche pas ça je le cache pas
malheureusement c'est plus faut vivre
dans le bac
9e conseil c'est vivre dans le présent
oui très important c'est qu'il présente
il faut être dans le présent il était
sujet qui est en permanence je trouve
que c'était mieux hier et ça déprime
bien sûr complètement ou qui ont décidé
en boucle en permanence qui tourne toute
la journée il est déprime il suffit de
noter l'idée en boucle sans un petit
carnet on n'y pense plus et on dans le
présent et le 10ème conseil c'est le
plus important les chéris je vous le dis
pour garder le moral et ça c'est fou
c'est donner régulièrement des chiffres
de l'argent de Radio France
[Rires]
qui se tiennent entre eux voilà
et il paraît que ça vraiment c'est
parfait pour le bonheur sachez-le voilà
non c'est j'active au maximum
intellectuellement ça je ne l'ai pas
mais j'ai rien ah non mais toi t'as rien
toi tu vas mourir dans deux semaines
on s'active intellectuellement et qu'on
veuille surtout des choses nouvelles on
sécrète de la dopamine et on a vraiment
le moral la routine n'est pas bonne du
tout donc faut faire des choses
nouvelles s'activer quand la télé
actuelle ment pardon est performant ça
va beaucoup mieux en trois semaines de
vacances faire 20 points de caution
intellectuel ce qui veut dire que partir
si on est déprimé c'est pas forcément la
solution d'accord
j'ai beaucoup de gens qui réagissent sur
mon téléphone suite à tout ce que vous
avez dit et qui disent c'est fou c'est
fou toutes les vraies questions
ce qu'il y a c'est que c'est plus et
souvent le matin
de l'anxiété ah ouais ça vraiment c'est
comme une boule qui arrive là
une boule surtout le matin pas le soir
et là faut que je me lève vite parce que
le matin tout ce qui est arrivé et c'est
Patrick Sébastien qui faisait ça qui me
disait je te jure que c'est des crises
le doigt dans le cul
[Applaudissements]
et donc oui et donc c'est vrai ça marche
vraiment l'anxiété le matin oui et c'est
il y a des moments dans la journée ou le
matin comme une crise d'anxiété ou tout
d'un coup c'est dans quelques secondes
ça c'est tout va mal tout
il a l'air un petit quelque chose très
simple à faire mais vraiment on prend
les deux mains
non on met les deux mains il coupe le
nez la bouche comme ça comme une
coquille on va respirer son propre gaz
carbonique pendant et donc tu souffles
et d'un seul coup on enlève les mains et
on se sent beaucoup mieux parce qu'on va
respirer sa rééquilibre donc faut le
faire pendant
voilà et ça donne
certains films aux États-Unis mais un
sac en papier ça je suis pas pour mais
le fait de changer les rapports des gaz
fait que d'un seul coup ça va mieux ça
donne un petit coup faites le test vous
verrez demain matin
Frédéric Salman la santé devant soi
merci
[Applaudissements]